now to breaking news overnight CBS News
has confirmed that U.S Marshals service
has been targeted by a major Cyber
attack Scott McFarland is following this
for us in Washington Scott good morning
what do we know so far and by we I mean
you Gail good morning officials say
cyber criminals were able to obtain
sensitive law enforcement data the U.S
Marshals service is an arm of the
justice department and is calling this
breach a major incident the ransomware
attack first reported by NBC News was
discovered February 17th officials say
the compromised information includes
personal information about certain
employees about wanted fugitives and
sensitive information about ongoing
legal procedures a spokesperson for the
U.S Marshals service says shortly after
the intrusion was discovered they
disconnected that Standalone system this
news came the same day U.S cyber Chief
Jen easterly warned cyber attacks can do
real damage to our nation leading to
theft of intellectual property and
personal information the Department of
Justice has launched a forensic and
criminal investigation into the breach
to try to figure out who may be behind
the attack Gail
all right to be continued thank you
Scott